progress in some areas like for example
self-driving cars has not been as rapid
as as everyone predicted and I think
part of the reason that it turns out
that driving a car in say New York City
in traffic with pedestrians and
bicyclists and all of that it probably
does require something at least pretty
close to human level intelligence in
order to do that to deal with that that
kind of a environment that is so
unpredictable and that's why the ironic
thing is that you know the taxi driver
isn't yet threatened but the the
consultant at Bain or McKinsey that you
know has has a Harvard MBA degree might
be threatened right
[Music]
thank you
it's great to welcome back to the
podcast futurist Ted speaker the author
of both rise of the robots which is a
New York Times bestseller and his more
recent rule of the robots how artificial
intelligence will transform everything
Martin Ford welcome back Martin thanks
for having me Andrew good to be here
yeah so Martin you and I met at Ted in
2017. I was very influenced by your book
uh rise of the robots which won awards
for its presence and you were digging
into the fact that AI was going to come
online it was going to change businesses
going to change a lot of things
um now is your phone ringing off the
hook uh with uh chat GPT arriving on the
scene is everyone like Martin Martin
what the heck do we do
yeah well I wouldn't say off the hook
but definitely yeah
I've been talking about from for a long
time is definitely getting a lot of
attention
um and you know yeah some you know both
of us kind of anticipated this in some
way right although it's interesting um
what you know one thing I've been saying
for a while is that I worry most about
the white collar jobs you know yep the
office drones rather than the truck
drivers and and
it does seem that it's unfolding that
way at least in the short term you know
it's more the knowledge type work that
that is really being impacted and and
less so the manipulative work although
of course in the long run everything's
gonna
be impacted well you can see robots in
Amazon Fulfillment centers that move
various uh packages around but to your
point a lot of manual work is actually
very costly and somewhat difficult to
automate because you need a robot with
digits that can go and grab things and
do things and process things one of the
examples it might have even been from
one of your books that I think puts a a
really good point on it is that it's
very very hard to make a robot that can
clean a hotel room exactly because you
think of the skills that are required
there the the dexterity the mobility to
the ability to deal with with really
unpredictable environments right
something different left in the hotel
room and you have to determine is that
something valuable that should be
preserved or something that should be
thrown away
um
you know human beings who are
extraordinarily good biological robots
right and and to build a robot that can
really compete with a human being in
terms of that kind of job it's really
still science fiction
and that's even more so for some of the
areas that we would really like to see
robots like in in Elder Care you know
Healthcare and so forth so uh Martin you
talk about how you think knowledge work
is going to be more readily automatable
which I totally agree with so how do you
see this playing out in various
organizations and we we just said look
cleaning a hotel room very hard to
automate having a robot do that's
difficult what is it easy now for AI to
do that people can understand I use the
example of call center workers myself
because everyone can understand that
there are two and a half million uh call
center workers in the US still I think
that's very very automatable and it's
going to be tough to see what those
workers do next
um they're making generally about 16
bucks an hour
many of them high school graduates what
what's a job where you think oh my gosh
like that the odds of that getting
automated are Sky High yeah I mean
really anything you know I guess the
first point to make is that it's not
it's not in most cases going to be about
complete jobs being automated it's going
to be about a large fraction of that job
being automated right a lot of the tasks
done within a particular job and and
some people will look at that and
they'll be very hopeful and they'll say
okay well
if only some of the stuff that I'm doing
is going to be automated then I'll just
spend all that time doing more creative
things and that will be too true for
some workers but I think for a great
many workers what happens is that you
might have you know three people doing a
particular job and then all of a sudden
half of what each of those is doing gets
automated and then you've only got one
or two jobs left right because it gets
Consolidated and I think that that's the
kind of thing we're going to see in many
fields it's not
it's not the case that a robot or an AI
is going to come along and there's going
to be a one-to-one correspondence
between the job that used to be there
and and the technology that takes that
job what happens instead is that tasks
get automated and then everything just
gets restructured and the definition of
job shifts and at the end of the day I
think that within organizations within
departments there are going to be fewer
jobs right there'll be fewer people and
more technology but the but the jobs
titles and and the functions of those
jobs will be different than what they
were before and you know I think very
likely that the people doing those jobs
will also be different in terms of their
skill set so but the bottom line is that
anything
of a white collar nature that involves
you know routine repetitive the best
word I think is predictable predictable
information
manipulation presentation
um you know that that kind of work
whether it's generating the same report
again and again whether it's the same
spreadsheet analysis you're doing again
and again
um even writing the same kind of news
article again and again I mean even
before the Advent of of Technologies
like chat GPT there were systems you
know generating news stories for
Bloomberg
and so forth and that's going to get a
lot better so anything that involves
writing presenting analysis and as you
say uh you know even customer service
interaction with customers although I
think in many cases that's actually
harder than some of the things that
you know if you're just someone
literally sitting in front of a computer
cranking away at a spreadsheet all day
or something that that's probably the
lowest bar in terms of I think what
we're going to see automated
but really it's across the board you
know I wouldn't I wouldn't point to any
particular
you know industry and say this is the
one that's going to be hit I mean
certainly areas like Finance banking are
going to be you know definitely impacted
but really it's across the board it's
any any kind of knowledge work
um that is fundamentally predictable all
right rules-based predictable cognitive
work now I I have some insight into this
Martin because I was a corporate
attorney for five months and uh it turns
out that even what people think of is
very high in legal work is very very
rules based and predictable the first
thing you do as an attorney on one of
these large-scale transactions is you
find a deal template that resembles the
deal you're looking at and if you find
the right template then the joke is that
you're literally just fighting and
replacing the names of the parties but
that's a non-trivial amount of even what
people think of as very very high-end
legal work I had a friend who worked at
Bain which is a prestigious consulting
firm and he said well AI can now do what
I took four years to learn how to do
in uh five or ten minutes because what
they might not tell you is that a lot of
these management consulting engagements
are very similar to each other you know
like there's something
you know if you do a supply chain
analysis for uh retailer guess what uh
when the other retailer comes and asks
you for a supply chain analysis you can
bust out the report that you did for the
other one of course you would never say
you're doing that but then you're just
you know like figure out what applies
and what doesn't so you mentioned
Finance which I totally agree is right
before this uh I I'm going to throw law
management consulting and accounting uh
into those categories yeah I think
that's fair
um and again it's not that all the jobs
are going to disappear or or that entire
jobs will disappear but it's just a lot
of what people were doing will disappear
and then you'll need fewer people and
and you know the thing that always
strikes me the kind of irony as you you
mentioned Bain you think about a
consulting company like Bain or McKinsey
the qualifications of the people that
you know you know fight to get those
jobs and get those jobs I mean you're
talking in Ivy League colleges and then
Harvard Business School or whatever
um and those people are yeah they're
going to be threatened by this but that
you know the the the person cleaning the
hotel room not so much okay and look at
the the difference in in education and
and and you know qualifications between
those two individuals so I think most
people would find it a bit ironic that
it's actually you know the hope the
hotel cleaner that that is maybe got the
more secure job
um as we look forward
I am pumped to announce that I have a
novel coming out on September 12th the
last election it's a political thriller
co-written with my friend Stephen Marsh
who wrote the book the next civil war if
you listen to this podcast Steven's been
a repeat guest even I became friends and
thought we should collaborate on a way
to scare the out of people but also
entertain them with a story of what
could happen in this upcoming election
or the election thereafter do check it
out at andrewyang.com books and there's
a special discount code last election
that you can use for 30 off at the
Publisher's website I'll be talking more
about this book but I'm so pumped to get
this out into the world last election
coming your way
well one reason why a lot of these jobs
are not going to be automated is because
it's so cheap to employ a human to
perform them uh you know you look at
some of these fast food workers or the
rest of it you look at it and say well
you know I can replace you but I'm going
to need someone around and you're only
getting paid 16 bucks an hour whereas if
you have a white collar worker that
you're paying hundreds of thousands of
dollars a year which is the case with
some of the uh
the incentive to automate is gonna be
much higher for those you know really
high paid workers and although what
you're saying about the fast food
workers and so forth is kind of
marginally true in the United States or
other Advanced countries like where I am
right now I'm in the Philippines here
is definitely the case you know that the
labor here is so cheap that it's kind of
hard to see why or how a lot of this
stuff would be automated but
um definitely in advanced countries
um I think we're we're getting to that
point I I agree with you that a lot of
the organizations that employ some of
these more expensive types of workers
are also in these industries where it's
ruthless it's hyper competitive they
just need to to deliver returns you know
what's interesting is I was talking
about Bane and my friend the former
being consultant who was like well like
there goes my four years of being
training uh Bain has actually been one
of the most early adopters of AI just
coming out and saying look uh we're
going to use AI for all of your stuff
uh and you know and then I heard about a
law firm that is essentially banned AI
um where that they're saying uh we're
not going to use it at all as you can
tell from from the way I'm framing this
like I think uh Banning it is pretty
dumb
um and I I have a friend who's uh
running a legal automation company
called legal nation and he said that
they're seeing more interest than ever
so uh this is in your last book you
called it uh as transformative as
electricity and saying your firm is not
going to use electricity doesn't seem
like a very winning yeah right so that
the law firm that you mentioned I I I
doubt that they're going to stick to
that I mean because they're going to
quickly find that they're they're just
not competitive right they're going to
be you know billing trying to build it
rates to support people doing the work
where other firms are are able to
automate a lot of that and they're not
going to be competitive right so yeah
you know the end game is that
I I think every profession begins to
look like
professional sports or or music where
you know you you know in order to
succeed you got to be a superstar right
you got this kind of Superstar effect
where you know a long time ago there
used to be
um lots of jobs for people like
Comedians and musicians
um
and even and even
um people that played sports right
because because there was no television
there was no broadcasting it was all
local right so if you want to go to a
sports match you had to go to something
in your or you want to listen to music
you had to go and actually listen to an
orchestra right so there were lots of
jobs but you know technology has
transformed that and created a kind of a
superstar effect where now a few people
in all of those fields can essentially
broadcast to the whole world and and you
know capture all the value and I think
that that we're going to see more of
that kind of effect in fields like law
and accounting and so forth where a few
people really Thrive because all the
nuts and bolts routine work is going to
get automated and probably the the
people that are going to really Thrive
are going to be the rainmakers right the
people that bring in business if you're
working for McKinsey and you're bringing
in new clients or a law firm you're
bringing in new clients then then you're
going to be safe right that's that's
going to be what matters so Martin you
have been hitting this message since
what year 2009 is when I wrote my first
book the lights in the tunnel which I
read
um of your four books have enjoyed them
all I'm a Martin Ford aficionado
so you have literally spoken around the
world to governments corporations
universities your Ted Talk was seen more
than three million times what
level of preparedness do you think that
that we have either in the U.S or
elsewhere for what AI will mean in terms
of the workforce education government
democracy media yeah I mean I think it's
a pretty minimal level of preparedness
and you know that's not surprising I
mean if you look at history the big
changes adaptations happen when we
really get into a crisis right I mean uh
we had the Great Depression and a Great
Depression produced Social Security and
unemployment insurance all of those
things would have been unimaginable
before that crisis so I've always kind
of felt that
you know the kind of things that you've
been talking about as well like a
universal basic income or or ideas that
I think need to be considered seriously
in order to adapt to this for the future
but it's it's just an extraordinarily
radical idea right in terms of the
political context especially in the U.S
and I've always felt that there's almost
no possibility of something like that
happening
until there's a fairly dire crisis right
so that probably will be what it takes
my hope is that by having at least a
conversation about this and making
people aware of it and maybe doing some
experiments with Ubi to gather the
necessary data information that we need
to really craft a program that if and
when we do get into that crisis then
maybe we can adapt pretty quickly but
you know just just in terms of the
politics in the United States which is
getting worse and worse and it's
impossible to do even the smallest thing
let alone something
something so radical like like a UPI
that uh you know I think it will
probably take a crisis you know before
before we really make those kinds of
changes and how how do you see a crisis
like that uh shaping up and incidentally
I agree with your estimation in many
ways back in the 70s when Nixon was
looking at basic income equivalent
um they actually did large-scale trials
in communities around the country saying
oh let's see how it goes so uh I uh
heart and back to that because it seems
like we're light years away from that
now in the U.S where if someone were to
look at it and be like oh let's just try
this in in places I think we should be
running trials all over the country to
your point but how do you see this
crisis manifesting yeah I mean it's hard
to predict right I mean for example when
you wrote your book you talked about
um trucker revolts right the truckers
were gonna block the highways and stuff
like this and as I said now it looks
like it's more the the white collar
that's progressing faster right so so
we're gonna see the white collar workers
maybe impacted first and actually
there's a hopeful note in that I think
isn't there because you know if it's
fast food workers and Walmart workers
then those people don't have a lot of
power you know but white collar worker
workers you know High income consultants
and attorneys and people like that I
mean that's
I mean that's more or less the backbone
of the the Democratic party really in
terms of the people that that you know
Drive the politics
um so I think there's some hopeful note
in that this might be a bit top-heavy in
terms of how it impacts and and actually
impacts some groups of people that
actually have more influence and power
over the political system than the other
groups of workers might and maybe that
will help to drive things a little
faster
foreign
we are living in the era of big Tech AI
chat GPT generative tools and these big
tech companies have made it a habit to
pick up everything we are doing online
why should they get our data and where
left out in the cold it's reasons like
this that I use expressvpn to hide my
unique IP address to make it harder for
big Tech to track me and my identity and
activity and encrypt all of my online
comings and goings and it's not like you
have to be a tech whiz to use expressvpn
literally just tap one button on your
phone or computer to activate it you
don't want your family to be vulnerable
and one subscription to expressvpn
covers me my wife and my kids on up to
five devices so stop letting big Tech
leech on your data freely use my link
expressvpn.com yang right now and you
can get three extra months free that's
exp r e s s vpn.com Yang to get
protected with a VPN rated number one by
CNET tech radar and most importantly me
expressvpn.com yang
foreign
so we talked about how you're likely to
have this kind of Superstar effect in
various Industries winner take all which
I agree with by the way and I I feel
particularly bad for young people
because I think that the folks who are
going to be in position to benefit from
the efficiencies of AI will tend to be
more senior in these organizations uh
you'll you'll have like this layer of
rainmakers tear point where if I'm the
person that the mega clients trust then
I can essentially name my price and then
there's the this entire layer of uh
Automation and AI below me and then
there'll be some people that help
Steward the AI and help hone the product
but if you're a young person coming in
it seems like the latter is going to
evaporate uh before you get there
especially because yeah no I think I
think that's a very good point um I mean
if you look at the nature of work
it's really the entry-level jobs
that tend to be more routine and
predictable because you know you're just
getting getting started right that's
that's the way organizations have worked
they give you know the you come you come
in your first job out of college and
they give you something that's routine
and predictable and you get started with
that but those are exactly the jobs that
are most likely to be automated so as
you say that that career ladder I kind
of
is you know kind of evaporating and I
think that's been true for a while it's
not just happening now I mean if you
look at the fact that
um you know we've got this this
phenomenon that some people call Elite
overproduction meaning that there are
just too many people graduating from
college and expecting they're going to
get these professional jobs and Aren't
Enough out there which is why you see
people with college degrees working at
Starbucks right as Baristas and that's
turning out to not just be you know a
summer job is turning out to be their
career right and and I think that that's
certainly the impact of technology and
the fact that these these jobs have been
disappearing for some time as well as of
course being outsourced to
to you know other countries is a big
part of that and it's going to get to be
a bigger and bigger problem in the in in
the further future it may result in a
problem of of really developing the the
kind of talent you need at the top as
well like you say right now there are
all these experienced people they're
going to benefit from this but those
people are not going to be there forever
you know nobody lives forever so if we
don't have this career ladder then who
replaces those people is are we really
gonna have ai that can replace CEOs or
or how do people you know get on the
path to getting that kind of experience
if if the jobs
um evaporate so I think there are lots
of issues for us there um and I I don't
know you know how it all plays out or or
or
um the answers to that but definitely
there you know there's just a whole
range of issues in terms of the job
market and and which jobs are going to
be there and how we develop the the
skills we need in the future yeah there
there is one field I think is going to
grow predictably and so to the extent
that this is appealing to people
listening to this or watching this
prompt engineer which is trying to find
exactly the right prompt to feed the AI
to get the quality output uh and it and
there are people advertising right now
for prompt engineer positions that will
pay six figures uh and someone compared
it to being able to use Google uh
believe it or not there was a moment in
time when people couldn't naturally use
Google I guess or like the Google search
was a thing so
um the better prompt the AI gets the
better the work product so if you can uh
feed the AI in a particular way you'll
actually have a job
um because there's going to be some
other person that wants to access the AI
but doesn't want to think about like
exactly what prompt to give it yeah so
so I mean you look at someone like me
I'm I'm sort of my more recent career
has been as a writer right I've written
books and articles and stuff I've all I
think I'm a fairly good writer maybe
that's you know a skill that's not
valued anymore right but actually being
able to write the material is something
that the AI will do but what matters is
being able to write the prompt to get
the AI to to write what you want to
write which is actually something I I am
not necessarily good at at all so so it
may you know not be so good for me good
thing I'm old right now but
um but I mean I worry about that I hope
that you know as a society we don't
start teaching young people how to write
you know like like that that becomes a
lost art or something because the AI
does it um so this is definitely another
concern you know that we're going to
lose a lot of
skills and capabilities that we feel are
important right
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
I have always been someone who thought
spending a little extra on your mattress
is a wise investment because you spend
let's say a third of your life on it it
makes you healthier more energized maybe
there are even other people that enjoy
your mattress too whether it's kids or
that extra special someone Helix sleep
is the mattress company we recommend it
includes 14 unique mattresses you can
have a personalized mattress shipped
straight to your door free of charge and
they are so confident they will give you
a hundred night trial yep you can sleep
on it for three months after you take
that Helix sleep quiz figure out the
best matches for you sent straight to
your door don't trust me alone my kids
also can't get enough of this mattress
Helix is offering 20 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to helixsleep.com yang this
is their best offer yet and it won't
last long with Helix better sleep starts
now
[Music]
so you you posed something very
interesting which is the idea of elite
overproduction and if you look at past
political revolutions throughout world
history a lead over production is one of
the preconditions to a political
revolution is that you have folks who in
this case let's say have law degrees or
college degrees and don't have good jobs
and they get pissed off and then they
start saying hey you know we we need
change in America there's been a group
of knowledge workers that have gotten
displaced over the last 15 years in the
tens of thousands they're all Highly
Educated they're actually good writers
and I'm talking about journalists
particularly local journalists I think
the number of displaced local
journalists is something around 40 or 50
um and one of the observations I made is
like how the heck did all these people
lose their jobs and there's no protest
there's no
demonstration there's no uh there's no
organization in
um by the way this is still going on I
mean like journalists are still getting
axed so when you talk about a bunch of
ticked off college graduates who are
underemployed and then they come
together as a political force
um historically you'd be right based
upon other societies but in the U.S I
don't know if I see it the
underemployment rate for college
graduates that I last saw you know
published it was 33 percent
um and then so you stack on the
unemployment rate you're probably
looking at something closer to 40
percent and so you have a lot of
unemployed and underemployed college
graduates now who aren't really
organizing into any I mean maybe they're
organizing in a particular way
um but uh that like that this the
American political system is fascinating
and that right now it really tends to
mute any uh
any voice
that is trying to make significant
changes and you know I've now dug into
this with structural reform and what I'm
doing with forward now you talked about
this group as the backbone of the
democratic party which you'd be right
since the Democratic party has become
the party of the college graduate uh
Coastal crew to a much higher degree
um I think it's one reason why you saw
student loan forgiveness
um as like an element of this past year
or two but I you know I I'm I think the
jury is out whether that's going to move
things in in this direction in terms of
addressing automation
um I mean I'd I'd like to think anything
would help because as you know like I
think that we need to speed up yeah
you're right it is in some sense
surprising that we haven't seen more you
know disruption as a result of the
impact on journalism I think is an
excellent example but I guess what you
see there I think journalism is a
perfect example of the kind of Superstar
effect I'm talking about right you still
got the people that are hanging on to
their jobs at the New York Times and
they're they are still the elite right
and you've got all these other people
that worked for all the other media
organizations newspapers that have lost
their jobs
and we don't quite know what has
happened to them they're trying to get
by writing you know freelance stuff and
then you've got these Superstars that
have gone to sub stack you know people
like Andrew Sullivan and Matt Iglesias
who are you know hoovering up money
right because because they were
positioned to do that right they were
already yep basically at the top of
their professions they moved over to
substack and it worked great for them
and so now you got all these other
probably thousands of people joining sub
stack thinking they're going to do the
same thing as Andrew Sullivan and and
you know it's not going to happen
because
but you know everything you look at is
is subject to this kind of power law
distribution right where where you know
the winner take all effect right where
you got a few people just you're just
minting money you know just just they've
got all the audience just like the
Superstar athletes and the Superstar
musicians you know just like Taylor
Swift right but then you get all the
regular people the the aspire to that
that are probably never gonna go there I
mean if you look at you look at
something like sub stack or or you know
trying to monetize YouTube videos that
kind of thing you've got a very small
number of people that do extremely well
and then everyone else it's you know
nickels and dimes right it's it's it's
barely lunch money but you've got all
these people you know I run into young
people now and and you ask them what do
you want to do I want to be a YouTube
influencer or something I mean it's it's
no more realistic than saying you want
to play in the NBA right I have kids and
and they also want to be uh YouTube
YouTubers I mean it's unfortunate
because you know you want to be what you
see so for all of our kids it's YouTube
and Tick Tock yeah but it's just not
something that can support large numbers
of people right it's not
gonna be like accounting where you
you've got jobs for hundreds of
thousands of accountants you know you
never you're going to have a few visible
people that do well at that but it's not
it's not enough to support people that's
why I I really think ultimately we're
going to have to have income
supplementation you know like Ubi or
whatever else similar to that that's but
something along those lines in order to
get support and and money to people
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you
Martin I remember vividly you and I
hanging out at Ted you just did your Ted
Talk uh trying to scare the out of
everyone
um I came over to you after I don't know
if you remember this exchange and I was
like hey Martin FYI I think you're right
and then yeah yeah I remember yeah and
and the folks around us
um kind of took the bull case where they
were just like oh you know new jobs will
uh originate because uh of these well I
mean this was the Ted conference and
this is
I mean technically there's a bunch of
entrepreneurs and Builders who are very
very optimistic to your point yeah yeah
yeah but but you and I were like look of
course it'll be some new great
coming but there's gonna be a lot of
very bad stuff for a lot of like regular
people yeah I mean but of course the
people at the Ted conference are not in
fact regular people right so they don't
they maybe don't
see that as clearly as as a lot of
average people do I think well I
certainly saw it and you helped me see
it you've been uh prophet and a
Visionary so what do you see coming down
the pike now and again uh you get calls
from uh very high-end organizations all
the time trying to get your crystal ball
uh like what are you seeing and hearing
um has chat EPT changed a lot of
people's minds yeah I think it's had an
extraordinary impact I mean I I don't
think there's any other
technology I can think of that in such a
small amount of time so rapidly has
really just caught the imagination of
the public and I think what's happened
is people have really looked at and they
said wow you know AI is really here and
to some extent that's true
um you know and yet the other side of
that is I think it's also it's also
overhyped a lot of people are looking at
at GPT for GPT and they're thinking this
is the emergence of of AGI right human
level Ai and I'm personally skeptical of
that
um I think it's an extraordinarily
powerful tool that's going to be used in
many many different ways
um but what it amounts to is a system
that can write or or speak but it can't
really think you know and there's a big
difference there uh
and you know some people do believe that
you know by the time you get to gbt 7 or
8 or 15 that this will evolve into
a true thinking system and maybe that's
true but I think there's a lot more
stuff that needs to be put in there um
you know my view on this is that you
intelligence probably requires
manipulating the world in some way I
mean you think of a human baby almost
from the moment they're born they begin
to reach out and touch things and and
interact with their environment
and this is how they learn this is what
they they this is how people achieve
what we think of as common sense right
which is
basically our under understanding of the
world the physics of the world you know
um and most of that is Unwritten and yet
with with
these GPT systems essentially what
you're talking about is a system that is
trying to become intelligent just by
reading right that's all it does is it
these large language models it
assimilates words right written words
and as a result of that it becomes
really powerful at generating written
material but can you become intelligent
can you really understand the world just
by reading well I I tell my kids the
answer is yes but uh in terms of Common
Sense we make a lot of assumptions about
what what we understand it's not you
know you know otherwise every book would
be ten thousand pages long if you had to
explain everything in detail right we we
make a lot of assumptions in terms of
common sense right and I don't know how
chat gbt can pick that up and how it can
really build a a true model of the world
and become intelligent also AGI which
you referred to is artificial general
intelligence where you have a thinking
machine and I agree with you that uh
this thing may not actually be sentient
uh in that way but I also think that
it's not going to make a difference for
a lot of practical purposes
um where if it can write a press release
or
an investment analysis or a newspaper
article uh in seconds
or a college paper I mean you know like
what what the heck does that mean I
think that's exactly right and that's
the point I've been trying to make I've
tried many times to make for a long time
is that
in terms of automating many jobs
probably most jobs you don't need human
level intelligence right because most
people are not
drawing on General human level
intelligence in most of what they do
most people are doing predictable
routine things that that you know
doesn't really require human level
intelligence um some aspects of their
jobs do but again what we're going to
see is all the routine stuff is going to
get automated and the only thing that's
going to be left is that that stuff that
really does require human level
intelligence and then that's going to
result in fewer jobs and that also I
think explains why progress in some
areas like for example self-driving cars
has not been as rapid as as everyone
predicted and I think part of the reason
that it turns out that driving a car in
say New York City in traffic with
pedestrians and bicyclists and all of
that it probably does require something
at least pretty close to human level
intelligence in order to do that to deal
with that that kind of a environment
that is so unpredictable and that's why
um the ironic thing is that you know the
taxi driver isn't yet threatened but the
the consultant at Bain or McKinsey that
you know has has a Harvard MBA degree
might be threatened right yeah it's
find note for us to end on which is one
of the things I observed in my book uh
what was that we're training people to
be more like robots and then rewarding
them for those capacities uh you know
where where if you think about our
Notions of work right now it's around
efficiency and sucking it up and uh
working to all hours certainly that was
the case in my old uh law firm and
various professions where uh you had to
be more like a machine and and I thought
the irony was that the more of the the
folks that we've tried to train to the
Moon we tried to turn into essentially
Cut Rate machines and then when the
machines become better able to do that
work then those people are going to be
like wait what you know I spent all this
time you know fighting for this role
um and meanwhile uh what we're going to
need more of uh has fallen under favor
which is stuff around Humanities Arts
creativity humanism really people have
gravitated towards technical Fields like
computer science and also economics
because those are supposed to be more
practical and there was part of me
that's like look guys I mean you basic
coding is going to get done by by
machines uh you know if you're trying to
economically optimize AI can figure that
out a lot of the time it's like you know
in many ways we have to be trying to
steer ourselves in other directions yeah
no I think that's right and I think kind
of the underlying problem there is that
the market doesn't value you know
Humanity Humanities and art and things
like that and that's why people have
been you know transitioning away from
that but as you say that's the uniquely
human stuff that will be left for us we
just got to figure out how we're going
to pay people to do that and again I
think that sort of gets back to a Ubi
type ideas right
um that maybe are going to be part of
that solution you know Martin you and I
should collaborate on what this economy
of the future should look like I agree
with you obviously that Ubi and uh what
you call the income supplementation has
to be part of it and I also agree with
you that's like hey there's a lot of
good stuff that we kind of want to see
the question is how do people get paid
to do it right exactly so it's it's um
something that a lot of people need to
think about so well hopefully we'll make
it happen together Martin
um a real pleasure what's next from you
are you working on a new project or book
uh I haven't started a new book yet I
mean there's so much unfolding right now
in AI that I think I need to wait and
see what happens and then write the book
um I think this this book robots is
still a very good overview of the field
you know for someone that that really
wants to
understand you know not just the
opportunities but also the risks the
things that are going to go wrong the
things that we really should be worried
about because I do think there are a lot
of things that we we need to worry about
and we should be talking about and and
probably taking steps to regulate you
know and it's not happening as fast as
it should be so I hope a lot of people
will join this conversation you know
because we really we really need that it
needs to be totally on the radar I
completely agree
rule of the robots how artificial
intelligence will transform everything
by the brilliant Martin Ford and the
very very human Martin Ford thank you
Martin for for joining us and uh we'll
have you back when Chad GPT 5 comes out
yeah if or or you'll have the the robot
version of me by then maybe but uh yeah
thanks for having me I was going to a
great discussion
as always Martin see you soon
[Music]
foreign